[Music]
jamila jamil has wasted no time bringing
fans into her world as she prepares to
film the upcoming marvel disney plus
show she-hulk
it's been a month since we first learned
jamil was joining she-hulk to play
titania the long-time nemesis of
she-hulk was similarly enhanced stamina
strength and endurance
she hulk will start tatiana maslany as
jennifer walters
an excellent lawyer who gains the look
and abilities of hulk thanks to a blood
transfusion from her cousin bruce banner
mark ruffalo will reprise the role of
bruce banner in the series as well
the upcoming tv show will be part of the
second wave of marvel's disney plus
slate
arriving in the same year as doctor
strange and the multiverse of madness
the 10 episode series will be directed
by kat koiro and anuvolina with jessica
riles serving as head rider
while there's a lot to love about the
team assembled to bring she-hulk to life
for now all we can think about is the
exciting video jamil shared from the set
this week
the good place alum uploaded the set
video to her twitter and instagram
the clip opens with a title card that
reads i can't believe i get to say this
but before revealing jamil in the middle
of combat training with professional
stunt men or possibly fight coordinators
everyone is moving at half speed which
tells viewers jamil is still learning
the moves for what looks like a big
fight sequence
she also shows off her athleticism in
the clip using all of her limbs to stun
her opponent
the camera then cuts back to another
title card that reads fighting my way
through the mcu coming to you in 2022
before cutting to a fun throwback photo
of jamil as a toddler
considering this is the first photo or
video from the set of she-hulk jamil's
update is major
as such fans of the actor and of the
upcoming she-hulk show couldn't contain
their excitement how do we know this
because those same fans were very vocal
about their excitement in the comment
section of the twitter and instagram
posts
one twitter user wrote i honestly forgot
you were gonna be in she-hulk so i had a
second time of feeling shocked and happy
about it
another wrote in part you and tatiana
maslany together
in the same show dara even dream the
same scene occasionally that's going to
be mint
it'd be downright rude not to watch that
over on jamil's instagram her celebrity
friends were just as supportive as her
fan base
liza koshy commented on jamil's set
video with an excited
hell's yes congratulations to dope queen
star phoebe robinson said
can't wait to see you kick butt one of
jamil's instagram followers also
commented on the video sharing an app
sentiment
the shiro we've been waiting for with
jamil's video now circulating around the
internet it feels like the door is open
for other she-hulk cast and crew to
share photos or videos from sets as they
prepare to shoot the new disney plus
show
time to start crossing those hulk-sized
fingers she-hulk fans
if you aren't sure who jamila jamil is
you've probably been living under a rock
as this british actress and comedian
star has been seriously on the rise
since 2017
after working as a british television
presenter jamil learned that acclaimed
showrunner michael shurer was
specifically looking for a brit to round
out the cast of his newest series
and ultimately jamil scored her first
ever acting role as well-connected
socialite tahani al-jamil
on sure's beloved afterlife series the
good place after playing tahani for all
four seasons of the good place jamil
picked up several other gigs including
voice work and the ducktales reboot a
hosting job on tbs's game show the
misery index and has helped promote body
awareness with her social media campaign
ai way now with her appearance as
titania and she-hulk jamil's profile is
sure to grow even bigger
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite tv shows and movies are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one